kw
leider neigt sich der sommer ja so
langsam dem ende zu was für viele
bedeutet beck das gehört zu uns und red
cafe als erster ist am frühen morgen
erstmal ein käppchen richtig falsch
erschöpft oder kaffee potenzial also
euer durch kaffee wach potenzial
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht voll aus also
auch okay wir werden beide energie
verbrauchen bein bewegen beim denken
beim verdauen food co die mehr energie
wir verbrauchen desto mehr adenosin
produzieren wir dass sich in unserem
gehirn anreichert unser gehirn hat so
genannte adenosin rezeptoren an denen
das adenosin andockt und zu unserem
gehirn sagt hey ich bin adenosin und du
bist jetzt ganz müde
koffein ist chemisch sehr ähnlich
aufgebaut wie adenosin und kann so die
adenosin rezeptoren verarschen und
selbst aline andocken
so werden die rezeptoren blockiert und
unser gehirn mehr nicht mehr dass wir
müde sind und so viel wir uns sache
außerdem stimuliert koffein die
ausschüttung von stresshormonen wie
adrenalin und cortisol die unter anderem
unseren puls und blutdruck erhöhen sind
dass wir uns noch wacher fühlen aber es
ist nicht am schluss im café direkt nach
dem aufstehen zu treten
unser körper schüttet nämlich auch
selbst cortisol aus um uns in die gänge
zu bringen zum beispiel nach dem
aufstehen etwa 30 bis 45 minuten nach
dem aufstehen gibt es einen regelrechten
kortison peak wenn ihr jetzt denkt da
hält sich jetzt noch eine tasse kaffee
obendrauf für den ultimativen energie
wird dann muss ich euch leider
enttäuschen denn genau das gegenteil ist
der fall
langfristig wird es nur dazu dass sich
euer körper daran gewöhnt und ihr immer
mehr kaffee braucht am effektivsten ist
es wenn ihr morgens ohne sehr einig
runde wartet bevor er zum kaffee treibt
um euren körpereigenen boost mit den
kaffee boost optimal zu kombinieren
alternativ könnt ihr natürlich auch
einfach mehr zählen denn wer weniger
energie verbraucht wird auch langsam
müde schön schlau
hallo ich bin die mai das ist schön
schlau herzlich willkommen bei diesen
ganz neuen kanal hier bekommt ihr
antworten auf fragen die ihr euch schon
immer gestellt habt oder auch vielleicht
noch nie gestellt habt habt ihr euch zum
beispiel schon mal gefragt warum man
cappuccino nicht so leicht verschüttet
wie normalen kaffee die antwort gibt es
nächsten donnerstag des wegs bitte
abonnieren damit wir uns nächste woche
nicht verpassen